all right Brian
yep Ryan where'd you grow up where are
you from originally Canoga Park
San Fernando Valley yeah and tell me
about your family
um my dad was deported like at uh when I
was a year old and my mom dropped me off
with my paternal grandparents
um that like
a year and a half too with my little
sister
and um took off went go and do drugs and
the game being and stuff oh really yeah
so your your grandparents raised you for
a little while
um my mom came back uh she she got with
my stepdad when I was like four
um and they had this bright idea of
taking us away
and collecting welfare
so that he could pay for their drug
habits
and I mean they just went downhill from
there
oh you describe your childhood in
general
horrific
uh volatile uh
downright crew where were your parents
your mom and your stepdad doing for
money
um my my stepdad used to sell me
um
yeah crack houses
uh
Tim you know support his habit
and my mom's
um
so
a lot of the times you know he would
just uh we would just you just
stuffed me in the car drive somewhere or
whatever you know or like force me to go
with him
and you're going to a house where
wherever you know sometimes in a house
abandoned building
like somewhere and
um
you know he would get money or drugs and
he would leave
and I would stay
and uh you know
it's a hell of a childhood
and your sister went through the same
thing
um for the most part I try to make it so
that she didn't
yeah like pick fights with my stepdad
and stuff like that and you know like I
love my little sister a lot
and you don't want nothing to happen to
her
and he knew that so
you know he he he he he was he wasn't a
normal person man you know like he he
had no soul like that man had no remorse
no nothing and it's like eyes
and
like
you know and he soon found it like you
saw that I would like pick fights with
him and and like I would do anything so
that you know he wouldn't touch my
sister like you know he like that's how
he would bend my arm you know per se
you know to get me to go to these crack
houses to get me to do things for him
none
you know
but for the most part how long were you
with your parents uh two and a half
years different just every day of that
and then what did you go after that
um well like on November 12th so far
like
um like he beat and raped my sister to
death
in a park
and like
she like died on like somebody's lawn
you know and uh
like
we went to the hospital from there and
they took me away from like everybody
like they didn't put me back with like
my grandparents and like I just went to
I went to foster care like the Nick
today
or no my bad
the next month I spent a whole month in
ICU at UCLA I was so malnourished had a
broken pelvis
um I had broken ribs
I had lacerations up and down my back
um
you know I was
40 like three pounds at the age of six
[Music]
um
I I mean I had bruises in various stages
of healing
Burns
he's still like play like uh you know
like uh
he called it fireflies and like he would
like put cigarettes out on me
and uh you know he would just tell me to
be quiet
when he did it and uh
you know like if I made noise he would
take it out on my sister
if I didn't like
it's just you know another Firefly
how far are you in school
um
initially I dropped out
um
my ninth
like my eighth grade year I I seventh
grade year I dropped out went back like
in my ninth grade year
like caught up really quick
um I was playing baseball
and then um like
I I threw up my arm and I go
and I dropped out
like the next year 10th grade
and um but I like around 19 I went back
and got my I got my GED and then I went
to college for a little bit and um I
have my
um my kdac it's a certified drug and
alcohol counselor
but um
so some college I guess you could say
you're you're now living on the streets
no I am yeah I last year I I kind of
threw everything away I had like my
grandparents I finally reunited with
them and I was like 16 17 because in the
state of California if you're in foster
care that your 16th birthday they send
you a paper with all the public records
of your like family like any relatives
that they have on record and stuff like
that they'll send you their name their
address and like a way to contact them
and like just anything that's on public
records about them
and um you know I reconnected with her
grandparents stuff like that but you
know last year that like
everything came crashing down again man
like we're finally got it got a break
you know I had a I had like two years
sober
um I finished school I was working in in
rehabs I was working at three have I got
cleanout and everything and everybody
died like my grandparents died on both
sides
um
my girlfriend died she got hit by a car
like you just uh my sponsor died he went
out after 22 or 23 years of sobriety he
went out overdosed
and died
um like like I felt like everybody was
dying around me and then
my heart gave out and I'd have heart
surgery
and uh
uh so on recovery like in recovery they
had me on Percocets and I've been using
her I'm a recovering I was a recovering
heroin addict
and you know I felt that buzz sitting on
on my cell phone my apartment and
like
I just I just
I gave into it man like I
ever like I didn't see a reason to be
sober anymore man I
I did a lot of it so that my
grandparents could see
like me okay because he worried so much
there was no bloody no more to worry
about me nobody could care
like nobody to go to
no one to call or anything like
I was lonely and
you know so I went back to it
and now you're using what fentanyl yeah
I'm using fentanyl now
it's it's crazy everybody's on this man
yeah like everybody
now people I knew from when I was
younger like messing around that were
like sworn like speed freaks you know
like I didn't even never touch an opiate
you know they didn't like being down
there on this stuff now
it it it's kind of like it's definitely
got like the lower class
like definitely in a grip it's it's
since it's insane yeah
yeah and what you're just staying on the
street
do you have a tent or anything
um I I had a tent
um Caltrans just took all everything
uh like I I got out like they told me to
get up here and I grew up I I grabbed
two bags like my two duffel bags that I
always carry with me and my bike and
they took everything else I just threw
it all away
and like right now I'm just like
crashing out wherever like I don't see
other people so that I don't get my
stuff checked
yeah
living on the streets is rough right
definitely
you've had bad things happen to you a
lot
uh
you get robbed every time you fall
asleep right yeah every time I fall
asleep like
now wake up and it's not always like
homeless people like I've had like
regular people pass by me
and see my phone see my wallet see you
know she like whatever it is you know
like if they liked it you know like to
them like they're I'm not worthy to have
it like I feel like that's what they
think you know like because they'll just
like if I'm not paying attention they'll
just grab it and walk away
and you know like being asleep like
like it's rough to go to sleep and like
you know not just the fact that I get
robbed like I have night terrors from
like my childhood I I go to sleep and a
lot of times I relive a lot of those
things
you know and
it's not fun closing my eyes
what do you do for money now
um
I boost uh you know I I like I'll hit
targets and stuff like that for like
various things like Cosmetics
um soap
um Levi's or whatever you know and I go
down to MacArthur
and I I sell it all you know everything
has a price
you know we get paid like
10 15 of what it's cost
and uh I'll do that
sometimes I'll scrap you know I'll pull
copper
um
I don't know I think whatever whatever
the hustle is for the day
how old do you know 24 24.
do you have any friends
on the streets you don't really have
friends
you just have people you get high with
but
I mean there's a couple of people
that I recently like left
because I
I don't know I have a problem with
commitment I have a problem about people
that care
um that
I could say we're friends you know I've
known them since I was
nine when I first started running away
you know like I've known them since then
like 15 years
um and they care they see me as like a
little brother I guess
but
I don't know like
I just have that like not having family
I have I get weird when someone tries to
put me in that like in that category for
them you know like when someone tries to
treat me like their little brother and
stuff like that and they're
don't have that I've never had that I I
don't yearn for that you know I get
really weird and so
you know I pack up and move
what emotions do you go through now
living this life emotions
um
I could go through mostly
a droning
just if I could express explain it a
droning gray feeling
like
there's hardly any times that I'm happy
hardly any times where I'm sad
you know I'm just worried like about my
drugs pretty much
yeah and like not getting killed
yeah
like
that's it and I I don't like I get like
the only emotions I get like I get
content when I get my drugs and it gets
hooked up or whatever and I get angry
when like it's all gone or someone
steals it like
other than that not not really much
every every now and then though you know
like
I'll have a good laugh or something like
that with somebody
but it's
I don't know seems few far in between
now
do you feel helpless against the
fentanyl addiction definitely I can't
get past three days without it
I think I've tried
like four or five times now like just
like quit like I like I freak out at
night and whatever you know and like and
I just like say [ __ ] it dude it's not
worth it you know like because with
Heroin I mean I I like heroin like it's
five days tops seven you know and and
like the rest of it's all in your head
like and you just like low energy you
know but like those first initial like
five days like he'll be throwing up
you'll have the runs you know like all
those like symptoms of you know kicking
and stuff but um
like with Federal there I get this
horrible anxiety
and like I have to get up I have like
it's insane like I've never felt this
way before about anything like not for
My Heroine not for anything man like I I
feel so wrong inside I feel so wrong
outside I feel so wrong period if I
don't have it
have to have it
you know I don't like feeling like that
so
I try to stay well
what's your biggest fear no
being a John Doe
like
I don't have family to identify me
I don't have friends you feel like
there's a better chance of you
dying than getting clean
honestly
probably
I mean I have heart problems
um I've already had three heart
surgeries
like open heart surgeries yeah but then
Sentinels and also A Dangerous Drug yeah
overdosing you voted before
um honestly like on fentanyl I've OD'd
less than I did on heroin
because it got me off the needle
so you smoke you smoke the fentanyl I
smoke it only
um I mean
that you know there are those times
where like it's day two and moving on to
day three and I have to get well
not I'll take like my nectar collector
like what I used to smoke it with or
like the the pens and stuff like that
the tutors and like I'll like run water
through them or like alcohol or
something
and something water soluble and I'll
draw that up and I'll slam that like
just the residue of it you know but like
rarely do I like throw like a rock of
federal into my cooker
[Music]
what's the roughest part of this
lifestyle for you
her roughest part of it
is not being able to shower
like
it just adds so much to everything
you know like you feel disgusting
because you
you look disgusting you feel disgusting
and people treat you like your an
illness
and like you'd be surprised what just
one shower could do like you shower up
put on some clean clothes no one thinks
I'm homeless
you know
like
I feel a lot better I don't feel
homeless when I shower
but there's just like
there's so many people that have ruined
it you know like I used to be able to go
into like a fast food restaurant or like
a Starbucks or something like single
stall you know like
and take me only like take only five to
ten minutes you know and be able to like
drop down into my boxers and wash in the
sink and that was enough you know like
you know at Starbucks there was a drain
there's a drain in the middle of the
floor like I could actually dump water
on me and like and then clean it all up
at the end and like but so many people
stopped didn't care about cleaning it up
taking two three four five hours in
there overdosing in it and now places
don't want any of us in there
like you know like it's hard to find a
place to like take a [ __ ] like because
they don't want us in there
how big a factor do you feel like here
the the sexual sexual abuse that you
went through as a young kid
played in where you're at today
yeah oh all of it all of it definitely
all of it I mean
from
the way I interact people
hike
you'd be surprised like how many regular
seeming people
bought me
you know like
not just like crackheads bought me
like
your regular
date run of the day Mill like just
middle-class person
has bought me more times than not
when I was younger
and like
seeing that just changed me like I don't
I don't know I don't I don't
necessarily like people
and I know you hear that a lot like a
lot of people say oh I don't like people
like I genuinely don't like people
I I don't
I don't connect with people correctly
you know because of it
like every day
people fulfill a role in my life and
that's it
you know you need that Mentor in your
life you know I don't connect with the
mentor for him I connect with him
because he's my mentor I need someone to
teach me
I connect you know you need a best
friend in your life you know someone to
help you maneuver through this because
you need allies you know I don't have a
best friend and I don't care about that
bird like person per se has their name
or anything they just fulfill that need
as a person
that is there by my side
because of it you know
and that plays a really big role like
on how much like
are you willing to walk away from things
like well like how much things weigh out
and stuff like that when you connect
that way
I think
I didn't care
you know and it didn't do much for my
self-worth
you feel like life is unfair
um
I don't choose to look at life like that
but yeah but definitely it is unfair
you know
like you should get cards that you get
dealt your cards I think if life was
fair you know like I'd probably be dead
too
you know I've had to do some bad things
I guess you could say just stay alive
out here
and life was fair you know I'd be dead
but
it's it's more like
life doesn't give a [ __ ] like it just
doesn't care
it will continue moving if I'm laying
down on the sidewalk overdose and dead
or if I'm in the back alley getting beat
all life will continue on
you know like
um majority I I probably have like three
people that would care
if that
if I died today
no one I don't have many people that
would think about me
wonder where I was at
try to look for me or anything
I'd be is it hard for you to hold on to
hope for your future
yeah
definitely
you know like
when someone wants something for you
you seem to want it more because you see
that
they're fighting for you and like you
see that that's good and and that you
need that and like them helping you and
all that it inspires you it gives you
hope
when you have no one
like
dude and you have a childhood like mine
so you don't have a self-worth
I
you know it all seems pointless
you know
like
if it wasn't for probably fair enough
probably would offer myself by now
you know
I pretty much live to get high now
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life Brian
the most important lesson I've probably
learned
is
what is done in the dark will always
come out in the light
you know what goes through the wash has
to come out in the rinse like whatever
you do
when I especially out here on the
streets it will be found out
if it's not today if it's not tomorrow
it might be two years down the road
you know like through a conversation
with between two random people and they
put it together and it will come and
bite you in the ass
you know like these these the streets
like
hey
it's vicious and everything in in all
ways but it's
the closest you can get to Fair
the closest you could get to freedom I
guess you could say some people say that
but everything you do
it either
is for you or against you it is not just
an action
you know it will close some doors it
will open some
or
you know it might be your demise and it
might you know benefit you but it will
be
for either your benefit or your downfall
the streets do keep count they do keep a
balance a ledger I guess you could say
you know and like
it's crazy that so many people that do
so much wrong have such a great sense of
justice
it's you know oxymoronic
all right Brian thank you so much for
sharing your story of course thank you
best of luck out here thank you thank
you man